hazardous air is affecting tens of
millions of Americans take a look at
these pictures because this is New York
City this morning
and this is the United States capital in
Washington D.C
I can't get over this the haze and the
smoke fueled by hundreds of wildfires in
Canada many that are still burning out
of control and take a look at these
pictures these are from yesterday where
you can see an eerie orange Haze over
parts of the Northeast including right
here in New York City where Health
officials recommended that people wear a
mask again and to give you a sense of
just how fast the smoke rolled over
Manhattan yesterday this image shows a
relatively thin layer of smog this was
at 11 o'clock in the morning
so take this in and this is the same
area just three hours later when it was
nearly impossible to see the skyline I
thought is there an orange filter on
your screen no there is not this is how
bad it was if you look at these images
side by side you can see how much the
conditions changed in just a few hours